at you understand that there are things
that are more important than just the
the the the ups and downs and the
vicissitudes of life
right that you're going to go back to
allah and that's inevitable
you know and that constant you know
reminder of death
helps you spiritually because then it's
not about what does this person think
about me
how good do i look on instagram none of
that's gonna matter
right you don't take your toys with you
when you go right and you can have all
the toys you want
at the end the end is the end
[Music]
i've done and again let me just give a
little trigger warning here
i'm not saying this that i'm proud of it
or that i'm condoning it and telling
people to do it
but like dude i've done so much
psychedelics
that i've seen the simulation i've seen
this matrix like breaking up this dunya
breaking up and
dude you ask any person who has done a
lot of psychedelics and they will all
report these same exact experience
salaam alaikum ladies and gentlemen guys
and girls welcome back to the t3m
podcast with your host fayad
rami and angel and we're joined with
another special guest
fahad sheikh ahat
why don't you introduce yourself sure
there's not really much to introduce man
just uh just a random guy out of out of
houston texas
uh you know here to like crash your uh
your podcast
no just on a more serious note um
so just about myself i'm married i got
five kids
uh i've been working in the field of
dawah for
20 years now i think um so i work with
an organization called aira
islamic education research academy it's
based out of the uk
and i'm also a uh i guess you can say
researcher instructor for
sapience institute so that's just
briefly about me inshallah more details
we
reached out to me or when i reached out
to you on instagram and you know we
started just chopping it up
uh getting to know each other on the on
the brief uh
i literally thought you were in your 20s
if not like early 30s
and then when you told me you got five
kids i was like mashallah man
yeah i told that to my wife and she just
rolled her eyes she's like yeah right
no no if if you're watching this just
know like 100 percent
in general
so uh you you talked a little bit about
how you're a part of aira and sapiens
institute right now
um why don't you tell us a little bit
about your background before that
how you got to there what you studied
what your interests were
and um if you want even before that you
can even tell us what brought you into
islam if you were
never really too much of a practicing
muslim to begin with sure
sure all right yeah so i guess we'll
start there man like why
uh how did i come to islam um
so i guess it depends how far back we
want to go but
uh so i'll just start with college how
about that so in college
um i don't know if you could even say i
was a practicing muslim
like borderline muslim maybe not even
muslim right
i was into basically everything
you know anyone that's been to colleges
into all right you can fill in the
blanks yourself
and um you know i graduated from
michigan state university
and uh my first job was at a a firm in
washington dc called
mci worldcom you guys probably don't
remember it but it was part of some
accounting scandal and the whole thing
came down
but that's a separate story and i had a
manager
and you know i was in their tax
department i graduated in accounting
again economics and accounting again
don't ask why
so i started in in their tax department
and i had this manager
and um again i'm not really into
religion i'm just living day by day and
just like you know let's just party it
up
it's just one thing after the other the
next uh you know the next ride that you
want to go on and
she comes to me and she says you know
fahad you really need to start thinking
about
uh you know god and uh you know you
should really accept the lord and savior
jesus christ in your life
so i'm like so i'm like i'm like look
man
in my mind i'm thinking like yeah i
don't i don't know much about
like islam but i know that's not really
where i want to be right
nevertheless we used to have these
really deep conversations
and at that time um because i was in dc
there was a
satellite branch of the jamia
um um there's a university in uh in the
riyadh
which had a satellite branch in in
virginia
and there was a there was a lot of
mashaya who would teach there
and they would hold like durus and
things like that and so one of my
friends
who i guess had gotten religious uh you
know told me he's like man i envy you so
much you live in that area you gotta go
check out their
drews right so i'm like okay like i'll
go there i'll go to their lessons or
whatever
and um so i walk in i remember the first
time i walked in so i'm this
clean-shaven guy you know just
whatever like totally not what everyone
else there looks like so everyone there
is like
totally in the phobe beard you know the
goofy and just
and i walk in the door and everyone just
kind of turns and looks at me and i'm
like oh my god i'm in the wrong place
here man i'm totally out of place
um but i went ahead and walked in and i
sat down
and um i think that i don't know if it
was that day
but i know later on um they had classes
by uh sheikh jafar dries if you're not
familiar with him
he is originally from sudan and he blew
my mind
because the things that he was talking
about like you know the things that we
talk about in ira and sapiens now
he was talking about it back then so
you're talking 20 plus years ago he's
talking about
the philosophy of science right and how
one needs to understand
before you go to college you need to
understand that there are philosophical
you know underpinnings to whatever you
study whether it's economics whether
it's
you know physical sciences social
sciences all of that has
philosophical underpinnings so we
presented islam in a way that
you know i i i think was very unique and
so that just kind of sucked me in and
from there
you know that's basically where the
whole story started and that's where i
started to study and
um you know i sat with some messiah and
you know started to
you know focus on on the arabic and
things like that and i can and then and
then i continued making dawa to my
manager
so so she was you know calling me to
christianity and we'd have these deep
conversations
because i was a novice um there was a
lot of mistakes that i made
right so we went in these conversations
i was telling oh man let me tell you 20
000 things wrong with the bible
right and we got into just this nuanced
discussion about the bible which
you know when you look back 20 years ago
you're like yeah that was definitely not
the way to go
you know um but in a nutshell that's
where the whole thing started and i like
to think that
the reason i i love the the the idea of
dawah and outreach
new muslims and things like that is just
because you know it was
by way of dawa right someone inviting me
to their religion that i
started to practice islam you know and
even today like uh not today but meaning
like
i think it was uh i reached out to my
manager
maybe last year and i told her you know
terry you're the reason why
like i actually started down this path
you know
and uh you know she's really nice she's
she's you know i
like i said i made some mistakes at the
time and you know now when you look back
in hindsight you think man
if i could do it again i would have
definitely added certain elements of my
character and things like that to
improve
how i presented islam so anyway so
that's a little bit about
my journey how i got here and then from
there i just you know step by step i
went to grad school
there was you know i went to actually
grad school in l.a um
and uh there was some misha in some of
the the the rougher neighborhoods
in l.a and i was able to study fich
with um a person who was offered to be a
party in saudia the first american
quality the first american judge
and he refused and he came back to the
hood and basically cleaned up his whole
neighborhood
masha'allah and so i studied some fic
with him
you know some of uh you know theology
akida with uh
and a few others in that area so and
that's what it was man i spent a little
bit of time
uh brief stint in in medina
and um you know and studied in uh
secular
uh universities as well so arabic
studies was at georgetown
uh ut austin i did graduate studies ut
austin as well
in uh middle eastern studies and
theology so just
i'm like all over the place in that area
i just like i just
different things interest me so wherever
i wherever i find something interesting
i just jump right into it
so i've been like that since the
beginning
so yeah man that's pretty much a little
background about myself
anything else any anything else you want
to know any other martial art i had a
quick question before the other two jump
in
um so just bear with me both of y'all go
for it uh my first question
would be what would the top three things
about giving dawah or topics that
interest you the most
so that's i would say that's evolved
right so in the beginning
um i'd say that my top three topics
probably would have been
um you know certain things related to
christianity you know
but over time because society has i
think
gone in a certain direction as well uh
that's shifted
right so nowadays i'm i'm more into
things like spirituality
uh you know the the you know as
hopefully we'll talk about the ontology
of the soul
um and then certain elements of
philosophy interest me as well
right because i think that uh that you
know when i first thought about dawah it
was all about kind of argumentation
and how do you win the argument how do
you win you know how do you
demolish the person in an argument and
over time as you develop and you come
closer to allah and
you start to study more you realize the
objective is not
to win the argument but it's to win the
heart right
and so because of that my own my own
focus has shifted
right so my top three would probably you
know ontology of the soul
uh spirituality and then uh you know
philosophy
um i had a second question
that's it for me and then we can insha
allah go on
so if the word soul didn't exist yeah
what would be the perfect word to
describe everything that it entails
if the word soul did like in english or
am i limited to english or can i uh
can i use the language no we gotta use
english you gotta use english
yeah so i mean i guess another word
would be spirit
right and that's where uh the term
pneumatology comes in so that's
another area of interest that i have
it's a study of the spirit
but usually it's done from the christian
framework so
when they talk about the spirit they're
talking about the holy spirit which is a
different
concept altogether but i would say a
close maybe
if you're not using soul then perhaps
spirit because
it comes from that uh the idea of
something that's intangible
yet fills the human being right and i
think that's closer to the concept of
well in arabic we're called you know
yeah that would
that was your second question you got
two yeah yeah
i have a good question though man go for
it so
i would say i'm more passing that stage
of
um just debate debate crush ruin them
kind of thing just demolish them man
that's it finish them off you're
finished
yeah exactly you're muhammad hijab's
face i've had a lot
so and yeah you're right with the issue
the issue with that is you're not
winning the person's heart
um and perhaps sometimes in a public
debate
your opponent if there's somebody like
you know abu jahed or something like
that then
crushing their arguments in front of
everyone else might open up their hearts
and stuff
yeah perhaps not i really like the way
hamza zorstus conducted himself during
the
debate with professor cross because he
would say subtle things like you know
i'm trying to connect with you i'm not
trying to like argue
but still from our perspective we would
say that he definitely won that debate
in
every manner masha'allah right
especially intellectually actually
so my question is
how do you when a person start or very
generally what did you realize
what did you start to implement so
um so let's go back a couple of steps
right um
first of all when i say winning the
person's heart
one of the things that we sometimes
forget about when we're in a
conversation or when we're let's say
debating someone
is that it's not only the person you're
debating
but it's also like if you it would be
beneficial for you to reflect on your
own
state as well right like when you're in
an argument
you know it's a very easy line to cross
between
you know i'm doing this for the sake of
allah and
i'm doing it for the sake of myself
because i want to look good right
like going from sincerity to ego is like
a quick jump when you're in an argument
because
the focus then becomes i want to win the
argument so that has
a spiritual ramification on you yourself
as someone that's
in that state right so one sort of
realization that i had was this is
actually affecting me spiritually
right and maybe that's a bit selfish but
when you're in a because
again you know if you're not there if
you're not let's say arguing for the
sake of allah then what are you really
arguing for
it's just to so that you're right you
know
and this is a this is something i think
people you know when they when they're
really able to hone in on this
they can apply it to every part of their
life like when a person gets married
and you're in an argument with your wife
right um
a lot of times it's just ego man like
you know you're wrong right you know
you're gonna be sleeping on the couch
that night but
you keep going right it's like someone
said uh there's a divorce lawyer he said
look man you can be right or you can be
happy
right so so i mean you make the choice
um and i think you know that concept of
understanding yourself
before you get into a straight-up uh you
know
debate or you know conversation with
someone i think it's really important
right and i think that had a lot to do
with my shift in
in focusing of how you know the idea of
focusing on the person
rather than focusing on the argument of
winning the argument right generally
in in our tradition in the islamic
tradition jiddal
or argumentation is considered a
negative attribute anyway
right um and that's why the prophet
muhammad saw
he said you know i promise a house in
paradise for the one who gives up
argumentation
even if they're right right so it's like
do i want a house in paradise or do i
want to win this argument
it's like the argument's not really
worth it you know anyhow so that was one
aspect
the second thing was just a
a general study of the human construct
which may seem a bit odd
right um a lot of times we forget
or maybe we're not aware that
you know the human being is created in a
state of goodness
right when we talk about the fitrah
that's a state of
of of purity and goodness and as you
know the prophet muhammad he says he
said you know
every child is born upon the fitra
is born in a state of goodness and this
can be
a really big game changer because when
you realize
that the person you're talking to at
their core
they're good they're pure that's how
they were created
right and that what your your goal is
just to take that goodness
and have it manifest and that's really
what you're trying to do at the end of
the day
you know and that has you know i'll tell
you something i was in um
just this concept of we're born in a
state of goodness
um i'll tell you two quick stories all
right i was in um
i was in uh where was it man oklahoma i
think it was yeah it was oklahoma and i
finished uh
the hotel the right the friday the
sermon and i was coming off the mimba
and the imam of that masjid because i
was visiting he comes to me and he says
look man there's a there's a lady in my
office she's asking questions about
islam
you're into this whole dawah thing so
can you talk to her
right so i walk in and she starts just
going at it she's like you know i heard
that in your religion
uh you know your prophet uh ordered that
there would be you know
you you know that the or the order the
slaughtering of 500
jews you know and all this stuff and and
i just walked in i was like okay listen
let's let's have a conversation just
just you know i just what's your name
let me start with that
and uh so i you know i was able to calm
her down and things like that
and and so we sat down and i asked her i
said what's your background
and she says you know i'm christian and
i was like okay now typically i'll i'll
put you guys to the test here for a
second
so if she said i'm christian from a
dollar perspective what should i do
what do you think where would you go and
either
any of you guys can answer that where do
you think i should go
if she says i'm christian i believe that
you know i believe in jesus
is as my savior what's next what's the
next step what do you think well
i'm gonna miss my i'm just gonna go
based off of what i would have said
a couple weeks ago a couple months ago
and i've been getting a little more into
emotional intelligence and what you were
talking about
instead of just always being on debate
mode yeah before i would always
you know introduce it with okay jesus um
you know i've been married
so i'm never claimed divinity like and i
can prove that
so i really don't need to say anything
after that
now i would more so you know kind of go
a little bit more into you know
why they believe that what led them into
it their upbringing kind of like nice
nice all right all right all right
anyone else difference of opinion
i would i would basically
make the connection that uh our god is
one
and that we worship the same god nice
and just make them understand that first
before
if at all i'm gonna talk about jesus
because obviously
uh if if the woman came at you like that
then she's already on the defensive so
you saying anything about jesus is just
going to make her close up even more
nice
nice all right remember you might take a
shot shot at it
very similar to fayad before i would be
more like
i would either just take like the hamza
you know hamza's then approach like why
and just keep pushing why
all right try and break down that
foundation and in different ways
using either the bible philosophy three
doesn't equal one that stuff
basically um but nowadays when i speak
to christians it's more like oh okay
what's your denomination and then i kind
of get a little bit more into it with
them
interesting interesting all right so you
guys wanna you wanna know what i told
her
what did he say so so we sat down
and i asked her i said look um from my
from my reading of christianity you guys
have a belief in original sin
is that correct and she said yeah that's
right i said so and that stems from
adam and eve eating from the tree and
then
because they sinned they were cast out
of paradise i was like is that
you know she said yeah i said look um in
our tradition
we have the same story except there's an
important difference
and that difference is is that when adam
and eve ate from the tree
um they asked god for forgiveness and
god forgave them
so we don't have a concept of original
sin like people are not born in a state
of sin
they're born in something what we call
the fitra a state of goodness
and then i asked her i said look um i'm
like do you give charity
at your church like you know do you do
tithe and stuff like that did you give
charity she's like yeah yeah i do
i was like when you give charity how
does that make you feel
like actually at your center it's like i
feel good
i said i want you to think about that
right why do you feel good
like you feel good like if you were if
your core state was one of like evil and
sin
you just gave someone money for nothing
in return
so your core state should dictate that
you should feel rotten
right like you just gave someone money
for nothing like if you look at this
from a
from a you know a benthinium utilitarian
worldview
like you should really feel rotten and
yet you feel good
and what we as muslims would say is the
reason why you feel good is because you
are good at your core right and that's
how
god creates every human being and so
this whole concept of
adam sinning and we're carrying that sin
we don't
hold that right we're responsible for
what we do but at the core we're good
so anyway so we spoke a little bit a
little bit longer and then
we did eventually get to jesus but by
the time we got to jesus
i think she kind of fully understood
that the whole concept of being sent for
the sins of humanity
it kind of it's it it breaks down when
you understand that human beings are
born in state of goodness
right and that god is like forgiving
from that perspective
um alhamdulillah and before she left she
took her shahada man she became muslim
so
i just wanted to throw in something
there that one of the main
misconceptions i get from non-muslims um
or even islamophobes to begin with are
that
you know it's your prophet or your arab
god
right right i mean it's like no it's
it's the one
when you really get deeper into it it
shows you how silly it is
no absolutely man absolutely i mean look
that's the thing i mean we live in an
in environment where people can come at
you pretty hard right
um you know especially how islam is
portrayed in general
i mean you're going to get a lot of
people with a lot of you know crazy
things i mean i live in texas man your
people come up to you and just be like
you know why y'all killing the people
and you're like what are you talking
about man
like what's wrong with you you know so
but just
it so it becomes a matter of not the
argument and my point with that story
was basically
you know i could have gotten into an
argument with her you know i could have
been offended
at that first statement because your gut
reaction when someone says
hey the prophet muhammad was a pedophile
right your gut reactions say
wait a minute and to try to go into
defensive mode right
or when she said um you know that that
your prophet uh you know slaughtered
you know 600 jews or whatever you know
your your gut reaction
is to go into defensive mode well no no
where did you read that where did you
get that and how do you you don't
understand the context and blah blah
blah
and uh you know one of the things that
i've learned over time is that you've
got to suppress that initial gut
reaction
and remember your your job there is to
win the person's heart
not to win that specific argument or to
clarify that particular point
and what's really crazy is that i was on
the plane back home
right from oklahoma and i realized i
never answered her first question
like that question about oh i heard the
prophet muhammad like you know
slaughtered you know 600 jews or
whatever it was
i never answered it but the interesting
thing now is that
when she now goes to the life of the
prophet sallam
and she reads about that incident now
she has the lenses of islam
to read about it so she's coming from a
completely different world view
whereas before she's coming from a world
view that's just
attack mode right so she'll be able to
she has the tools now to understand
let's say a particular incident right or
the marriage of the prophet saws or
whatever it might be
you know so a lot of times we get into
this gut reaction to just go into
defensive boat and say no that's not
true
right um and sometimes it's just about
look what's
what's the goal the goal is to win the
heart of the person you want to connect
this person
so on the day of judgment when you're
standing before allah
that this person can't say you know what
fahad they never
told me about they never told me that oh
there's only one god and there's only
one god worthy of worship
you know you could have gotten into some
conversation you know some somebody
comes up to a sister in hijab
why do you wear the hijab you know and
then oh well you know it's because of
modesty or whatever gives
all the reason the world and let's say
this person says
you know what you're right the
appropriate level of modesty is the
hijab
right and they die so the question is
will that fact
save them from the hellfire no
right because if they're still believing
that you know that that
god is one and three or whatever it
might be or that you know what i'm
worthy of worship over god or whatever
it might be
then you really haven't done much you've
convinced them of some random
position in islam but you really haven't
won the person's heart and connected
that person
to their purpose in life right so
anyway so the second story i was going
to tell you
was that we were in uh new zealand
myself and some of the ira guys
uh right after the shootings happened
there yeah uh and then we went back the
year
the year after because they were
supposed to do a uh like a year
anniversary of the shootings
so we did a presentation we basically
traveled through new zealand like city
by city
and we went to this you know we went to
different cities and one of the cities
we went to
i explained this idea of the fitra and
then i said
i said look man just be real with
yourself
when you see a newborn child do you
think to yourself
ah look at that sinful little rat or do
you think look at that innocent little
child
right that if something happened to that
it's innocent it's pure like
what is your natural state when you look
at that child
so if you take a world view that says
we're all born in a state of sin
that child should be evil right at this
at the onset
but from the world view of islam the
reason why you have that natural
intuitive inclination to think that
child is innocent
and pure is because every child is born
upon the fitrah and we don't hold that
belief
our assumption when we meet people our
assumptions that you are good at your
heart
and you're good at your core before we
assume that you're bad
that's a that's a concept within you
know across the board in islam
so this lady after she finished she came
up to me and she says you know my whole
life
i've always had this problem with the
original sin that you know and this was
the main issue was
how could you say that a child is in the
state of sin and she's like you just
clarified it for me like what you said
was
was very profound you know and so
um my point in mentioning these two
stories is that
understanding that the human being is
good at their core and our
job is not to win the argument but to
have them realize
their true who they are right and who
they are
are based on their fitra are people who
are beings that were created by allah
with a purpose to submit to and love
allah
when you have that in mind then it just
it changes things
you know across the board so anyways
that was a really long-winded answer to
your question man no that that was a
great one uh
when you had told her all this and you
got to
the subject of the isa of jesus
yeah peace be upon him what did she
say like how did she react to that and
like how did you present it to her
so what i present the way i presented i
said look i'm not asking what you
believe
but i'm asking what do you think is
right like if i presented this to
an eight-year-old or a nine-year-old if
i i have the islamic framework in front
of us and which says that human beings
are born a state of goodness
that jesus you know who he was was a
messenger of god
that you know from the islamic framework
he didn't die
you know and wasn't crucified and the
whole concept of sins is not from
someone else but
you're responsible for you i'm not
asking what you believe
i'm asking which one do you think makes
more sense
right i'm saying just just be honest and
um
and again i'm not asking what you
believe or what you hold dear i mean
that that's
i totally respect that and i don't
totally respect that but yani
like you know i just asking what do you
think and she was
it was a moment that she just kind of i
think she was just really honest with
herself
and she said well you know what what you
said makes more sense
and it actually you know it it's it it
it resonates more
you know and then she started talking
about how she always had a con had a
problem with the concept of jesus and
all these things
which i think maybe she was struggling
with before you know
um i just think that if i'd come out
just
right through the door and said like you
know jesus is not god
and uh you know you know how can you
know what do you mean one plus one plus
one is is
is one that's the stupidest thing i've
ever heard you know i mean it would have
been a different conversation
right because and that's the thing like
every
so every human has their fit at their
state they're good
but human beings also have desires right
and one of the things one that part of
our desires aside from
food and drinking and you know eating
and you know and
relations marital relations is your
desire to be right your ego
you know and understanding that this is
a you know a constant struggle with
people
is that how do i you know i've got this
pure goodness inside of me and get my
desires always pushing me away from it
you've got this
internal struggle right and that that
internal struggle takes place on the
heart
and you know scholars say that's why the
the arabic it's called
it's called because it comes from you
know to to overturn
right the term comes from to overturn
something like boiling water so it's
just oh constantly because your heart is
always in this
battle going back and forth right you
always want to do good sometimes you
fall and then sometimes you come back to
allah
um and once you understand that that
you understand that that's true for
human beings in general
that they're going to be struggling with
their egos as well and that's why you
know when it comes to like
live debates i'm not a fan of
proliferating the idea of having debates
like all the time as a dawa tool right i
mean
it's certain context it works you need
to put them in in their place you know
certain times sure
but as a as a dawah tool i find debates
um i i find you you can be
i don't know how much dawah you're
getting done in a debate right because
if you think about a debate
people show up to a debate with their
team in mind
right like you're gonna go to a football
game you've got your team that you're
rooting for
right and um and so it's basically you
want your team to win so
it's not really here's a sincere person
but here's a person that wants their
team to win so egos are at their highest
in debates right and one of the hardest
things
when you when when you're trying to win
the heart of a person to battle is their
ego
because that's something that you know
if you think about even within the
history of islam
you look at the one of the worst people
abu jahl right
i mean you can't the prophet sallam said
that abu jahl is the
is the faraon is the pharaoh of this um
of this of this community
right so he's for the muslims he's like
the pharaoh of the muslims
right and when they asked abu jahl
they said look man this man he came he's
a prophet he claims to be a prophet
and what's do you not believe that and
he didn't say no it didn't rationally
make sense to me or
no he's not a prophet what he said was
look man i'm from the tribe of i'm from
the tribe
of uh mazzum banu maxum and the prophet
muhammad is from the tribe
of um banu hisham right and so therefore
we have always historically been
competing with each other
when they would give water to the people
making hajj we would give them water
when they would give them food we would
give them food so we were always in
competition
and now you're saying that they have a
profit
how can we compete with that i will
never accept him as a prophet
right nothing to do with the rationality
it's all about
my tribe versus that tribe it's all ego
right and so a lot of times when we're
when we're
when we're when we're talking to people
it becomes it behooves us to understand
that you're talking to a human being and
not a
a mechanical logical robot so you've got
to deal with things like their their
base state their goodness but you also
have to deal with things like their ego
you know you might be talking to someone
in a group
and that person because of the fact that
you're in a group um
they might not accept your message even
though internally they've accepted it
like there was a guy i remember some
time ago you always have these um
these dawah tables uh you know on
college campuses right where you
you set up your table and you know
you're calling people to islam
and he used to come and used to just
incessantly argue like just back and
forth
and eventually became muslim and he said
uh we asked him later on like you know
so all those times you're arguing he
goes you know
i knew you guys were right but i just
didn't want to lose the argument
i knew in the beginning you guys were
right i just didn't want to look bad
you know i just i didn't want to lose
the argument so
the kind of the second part of that
construct of the human being is that
look there is a fifth round there's
goodness but there's also the challenge
of one's
you know one's kind of um you know
desires
right and one of the main desires that
you have to contend with is a person's
ego
you know if we think about so the the
construct of the human being you have
a um an internal reality
all right so let me let me take it from
a different perspective
you know there's a verse in the quran
where
allah says uh
do not be like those who forgot god so
god caused them to forget themselves
right
now if you were to just read that verse
you think wait a minute who is
who are the quintessential people who
have forgotten god or don't want to have
anything to do with god like
like who are who what category of people
is that you'd probably think okay
they're probably either atheist or
agnostic
right that they're they're they don't
have anything to do with god it's just
and how have they forgotten themselves
like this verse says if you forget like
you know do not be like those who forgot
god so god will then cause them to
forget themselves
how they forgot themselves they probably
still get up in the morning brush your
teeth
they probably have certain you know
certain things that they want to
accomplish in life right they want to go
to college they want to get a good
career
uh you know maybe they want to get
married or have you know relations
how have they forgotten themselves so
the question then arises when
when allah says that they forgot
themselves what is being spoken about
but the question is
what does it mean what does a self
really mean like what does that signify
right and a lot of times when we think
about the self like who am i
we define ourselves by way of somebody
else or
something external to ourselves right so
if it's social media
it's like how many likes do i have on
this post that's how you're defining
who am i right but when i'm when i'm
talking about when you ask a question
who am i i'm talking about
your essence and your reality like what
makes
you you you know so like
um if tomorrow like they they they have
a policy here in the states i guess
you know and and they say all right you
have to change your names if you have a
muslim sounding name
you got to get rid of it so instead of
fahad you got to be frank
right or whatever right instead of
ramming you got to be robert
whatever it might be so does that change
who you are as a like internally like
does that change you and your your
conscious reality
it doesn't right just a name change
right there's
there's a conscious reality that makes
you you
right um if you got into a car accident
god forbid you lose an arm
are you still you yeah right
you're just missing an arm right if you
lose god forbid your other arm are you
still you
yeah let's say you lose your legs god
forbid are you still you
so what constitutes you is not your
physical
body but it's something that's much
deeper than that
and from the islamic framework we say
that is your your ruach
your spirit and your soul right so
the one who forgets god it's not that
they forget their physical reality
they forget who they truly are in the
sense that they have a spiritual
inner consciousness that is
who what makes you you when you um
like what's what what's what's your
favorite food man just throw something
out there
any one of you guys um
favorite a lot a lot a lot
just one of your favorite foods my name
imma name an ethnic dish
for those of you that might know what it
is what is it called the haleem
haleem okay i've had haleem anyone else
had haleem
nobody oh man that's a shame man make
doba
repent no i'm kidding all right
haleem you know when you eat haleem you
have a certain
inner subjective experience meaning
that what you could describe what that
haleem is like you could say it's got
you know it's got some spice it's got a
little tang you know it's got this
texture which is
you know and it's got a little medium so
it's a little meaty but i can never
know what it's like for you as an
individual when you eat the haleem
that experience that you have i can
never tap into that yup even if you have
the exact same claim that i'm having
yeah because that is subjective and
inner to your experience only
so what makes you you is something much
deeper than just your physical body
right and from the islamic framework
that is the the rule
the soul and so when someone forgets god
it's not that they've forgotten their
their physical reality but they've
forgotten their true essence
and that essence that god has placed
inside the human being which is the
ruach
right um and that constant struggle that
i was talking about
it's a struggle between the rule that
internal reality that soul that spirit
and your physical desires
because your physical desires are housed
in your physical body
and that's why when you look at um books
on spirituality like ibn al-qaeda
right very famous uh scholar uh uh imam
al-ghazali for instance
you know they make this interesting
analogy between the human being being
not an angel not like angels and not
like animals
and yet it's very unique because with
angels
whatever they're commanded they do
they're beings that are pure and
you know made of pure light whatever it
might be they have this purity and
they can never disobey allah right
animals
in a similar sense can never disobey
allah because
there's no inner reality or inner um
kind of inner morals let's say or inner
soul that gives them some sort of
decision-making
capacity in terms of morals right so
whenever they feel hungry
because that's what that's how they are
naturally they eat
whenever they want to have relations
they do that right
there's no concept of you know what i
shouldn't do this it's not like
a lion is chasing down a gazelle and the
gazelle said stop
what i find you're doing is it's morally
reprehensible sir
you know it's it's that's how they are
naturally right
so the animals have this you know
physical desire that defines them
and the angels have a certain reality it
defines them the human being
is a constitution of both of these type
of elements the
is part of that angelic reality that you
have and the body the badan
is part of the animal reality and so
when you obey allah you're spiritually
connecting with the creator of the
heavens and the earth who put that ruach
inside of you put that soul inside of
you
and so you become better than the angels
because you did it by way of a free
choice
right and when you choose to just go
with your desires like i do what i want
right and i'm just going to eat what i
want to eat i'm going to basically
relations whoever i want to have
relations with whatever it might be
you become worse than the animals you
see
right and so that position is something
that's uniquely human
and we have by way of what our actions
we can become better than angels and
worse than animals
and so when we forget ourselves that
spiritual reality
we've disconnected ourselves from allah
we've forgotten allah so anyways that
was a bit of a tangent but
i actually forgot the initial question
it makes sense though
yeah it makes sense because if you think
about it
like when we are given something whether
it be from a family member or a friend
we we thank them right we're grateful
and like and if it's something that
we're using on a day-to-day basis like
we may thank them multiple times we may
think them
until that thing just no longer works
anymore even then we still might thank
them
right and like you're saying when if if
someone is just saying ah where's my
body i'm just gonna do whatever i want
it's it's initially like you're giving
the gift and you're just like
all right you know you're not even
you're not even thankful you're not even
grateful for it
right no it's true because then the idea
is are you
worshiping god are you worshiping
yourself right
i mean it's it's your choice right no
there's no such thing as absolute
freedom
that's just you're gonna you're gonna
have servitude to something either it's
going to be yourself and your own base
desires
right or it's going to be the one that
created you and true freedom really
comes from the one
by by submitting to the one that created
you because he knows you he knows what
he created right
does he not know what he created of
course he does right is he not looking
for your best interest of course he is
do you have the entirety of the spectrum
of knowledge
to know what's good for you no your
knowledge is limited man
so if your knowledge is limited it's
like when when you go to the doctor
you know you don't you don't mistrust
the doctor and say look man you know
like
you want me to take this medicine but
i'm not gonna trust this until
you know i go to medical school i go
through the entire degree process
and all that stuff and then i'll
understand well no
right you have a concept of trust and
it's you know
obviously the highest examples with
allah
but there's no there's no reason why
that becomes something of a negative
aspect that's a positive thing
that you've now taken the breadth of
knowledge that comes from the creator of
the heavens and the earth
and you're tapping into that because you
realize that as a human being your
knowledge is going to be limited
that's part and parcel of being human is
that you have limited knowledge
like as allah says
we've only given you just a minuscule
amount of knowledge
right and when the quran mentions the
knowledge of allah
this is like if all the trees became
pens and the oceans were ink
and you tried to you know you know
expound upon the knowledge of allah you
would still not exhaust
the knowledge of allah right so there's
that knowledge and then there's your
limited knowledge and you're
making all of these you know profound
deep you know decisions
and you know you're you're judging
people i always tell people i said you
know the
the the term prejudice it comes from you
know pre-judging
like you don't know the reality of that
human being that you judged
you don't know where they're coming from
you know you don't know their background
you don't know how their day went you
don't know if they had an argument with
their spouse in the morning you know if
they're just about to get a divorce
nothing about them and you're making
judgments based on this
little bit of knowledge you know it's
really when you think about the human
being
from an external point of view it's
really fascinating because the things
that we do as humans
you know it's just uh it's just it's
funny sometimes right
we make these prejudgments and you know
we don't we don't think about well
what am i judging what how am i how am i
judging this person
you know and at the end of the day do i
want good for this person
but anyway so i don't know
man why don't you go a little bit deeper
into the into the row
okay so let's see where do you want to
go from here
how about this let me let me mention
something related to the quran
right perfect man and um so there
is let me see here let me just uh
there's actually something i wanted to
share with you guys which i think you
will
you'll appreciate um and this goes back
to
kind of the the the uh the precision of
the quran
and how um how amazing the quran is
okay and in the quran
there's a linguistic tool uh which they
call
which are grammatical shifts okay
and so you'll find that sometimes when
allah is speaking to a person
it'll be in the first person right like
you
or another time he'll be talking to the
third person like he she
it and in certain circumstances allah
will be talking about himself like i
we you know i did this we did this and
when that shift happens
those shifts are very profound all right
so there's a grammatical shift related
to the rule
in surat sajdah right and i think i mean
i thought it was pretty mind-blowing
i don't know maybe you guys might might
not i don't know but surah sajdah
um it it basically it's there's a
when you go to i number i'm trying to
get the number here
yeah so i number seven uh actually
number six starts with
allah right uh that you know that he is
allah so and so forth and then it goes
on
i number seven says
that he is the one who perfected
everything he created
and he arranged and he originated the
creation of human uh humankind
from teen from clay all right so now
um let me ask you guys are you guys
familiar with
i'm gonna get some english grammar now
first person second person third person
what's first person you didn't
you guys didn't think you could get
tested did you you wanted to respond
yeah man okay that's what makes this fun
i'm
i'm going here perfect all right that's
first person what's second person
you're going there brilliant and of
course third person
he she it right so this verse
the one who has perfected everything he
created and he originated the creation
of humankind from clay is this
a first person second person or third
person
third person brilliant okay the next
verse
and then he made his descendants from an
extra
an extract of humble fluid in other
words sperm right
all right first person second person or
third person
same third person all right so we're
third person so he's talking about the
creation of the human being
in general created from uh from clay
then he's talking about generations
moving forward like through sexual
relations
so again his third person that that's
how generations move forward he made his
he made you know his descendants human
beings descendants from an extract
of sperm basically extra humble fluid
and then
and this is the part
right and then he fashioned them he put
them together and then he
blew or the spirit the ruach into this
creation
first person second person or third
person
we're still at third person right now
here's where the grammatical shift
happens
and then he gave you hearing sight and
intellect
now why is that remarkable because
up to this point it was all third person
he did this to that particular thing
that particular thing
after he puts the rule inside the human
being now
because you have a ruh inside of you you
have a consciousness
he can address you
right so now he's seeing
hearing insight and minds why the whole
reason that you can function you can see
something
is not the mechanical function of the
eye what really
how you see things is by that that
consciousness that soul
right otherwise it's just a mechanical
object that is your eye that has a lens
but what truly sees so that grammatical
shift happens in the quran
because of how that reality is is
manifest
you get that i mean i thought that was
pretty mind-blowing i don't know maybe
you guys uh
like that it definitely is
you know so um so when it comes to the
rule one of the other things
uh that's interesting about that is
um like the month of ramadan i think
this is really fascinating
when you know what when you think about
the month of ramadan what what defines
the month of ramadan and i don't mean
the religious answer like taqwa or
something i'm just saying
let's say you ask a non-muslim like who
has some knowledge of islam what what is
the thing
that you think about when you think
about ramadan fascinating
fasting right like you think you can't
eat right like that man that must suck
right so you just can't eat man from sun
up to sun down
so the thing is is that when you think
about
um the the person who's on this
spiritual path to be connected with god
11 it's like 11 months of the year
you're basically eating whatever you
want in general i mean i'm not talking
about the certain limitations we have
like pork or whatever
but in general you can eat whatever you
want 11 months out of the year
and this one month of the year it's
allah is telling us
look from sun up to sun down that thing
that's allowed
11 months of the year you're not gonna
do that
you know so that sustenance
that that that food that you eat to
sustain your physical body
you're gonna limit that all right
when we talk about the physical body
where does its sustenance come from
where does it
like you eat from the ground right
i mean eventually i'm not talking about
like yeah maybe mcdonald's is the
exception
no no i'm kidding but but generally like
the food you get is from the earth right
it's not from outer space or anything
it's like from the ground like even the
cows or whatever you whatever it is that
you eat it's
so the human being in order to sustain
its body
it eats from the same source as it was
created right so we just read is created
from clay it's created from the earth
right so that's your physical body
but you also have a rua so if you want
to
sustain the rua you want to give your
nutrition
what gives the nutrition and
the thing is is that when the question
of what is the ru
or what is it what is its reality
there's a verse in the quran where allah
says yes
[Music]
they ask you concerning the ruh they ask
you about the rua this soul
they're asking about and the response is
say that the is from the command of god
right now this command of god
you know it it's it it takes various
forms and so
one of the ways in which this command
works is that when allah says something
or commands something
it just happens right so
when he commands when he orders a matter
he merely says to it be
and it starts to exist and you know as
human beings we have a hard time getting
our heads around that sometimes like
it's just a word but we do that in the
in the in the area of
if you ever study the philosophy of
language this is there's a concept of
like
our words becoming our actions that when
we say something it's
it's the action like when you
congratulate someone how do you do that
you congratulate congratulations the
word is the action
right or if you want to thank someone
thank you well that the word is the
action
and of course the highest examples with
allah so when he wants to bring
something into reality he says
be and it is so what
this rua it comes from this the the um
the the command of god and how does the
command of god work it works by
his words okay so do we have
access to the words of god the words of
allah
of course it's quran right
so in the month of ramadan it's like
that body that animal desire that you
have
you're being told to constrict it all
right
to calm it down and when it comes to the
soul
the ruach you're told now to do what at
night
recite the quran now
the body is getting its sustenance from
the place it came from
the is getting its sustenance because
why
it comes from the amer the command of
god which is by way of his words
and the quran is the words of god so
that recitation
is giving that sustenance to the soul so
you're elevating the soul in ramadan
and you're kind of depleting the body
you know and sometimes
uh you know they give the example of a
horse rider like you're riding a horse
and um you know your soul is basically
the rider yeah
and so when you're going to be riding
this horse you want to
you know if if the horse is well fed
it'll take you wherever
it wants right because it's got all the
energy wherever it wants to go right
that's like your your desires your your
animal base state
so when you're well fed and you're and
your soul and the rider's weak the soul
is weak
the horse will take you wherever it
wants you to go but
in the month of ramadan you're weakening
that horse right you're not giving it
food
and you're strengthening the rider and
so now you're in more control
then you're in control of the horse
right and that's what the month of
ramadan in fact does it's to elevate the
soul by way of the quran
and to weaken the body and so that's why
even during the year
we're recommended to fast like mondays
and thursdays you know three days of the
month
why it's not just in a vacuum it's to
develop you spiritually you know a lot
of times people look at like the
physical fitness aspect of fasting
and they miss the point of that it has a
spiritual significance that is just
amazing when you think about it yeah so
and allah yeah so i mean and
that's the thing man uh when it comes to
your your reality your reality is one of
a of a spiritual being
and once you understand that about human
beings in general
how you approach them is going to be
very different right
yeah yeah subhanallah i'm like
rethinking my entire way of life now
i shall hopefully for the readiness
we're ready for all these paradigm
shifts
yeah yeah i mean that that's you know
i'll tell you another interesting one
um and this one i think it gets people
sometimes
if i asked you um this goes back to a
concept of the fitrah but
if i asked you how would you categorize
rationality like how many categories do
you think it has
right most people would say you have
things that are rational or things that
are irrational things either make sense
or they don't make sense
right so a rational statement would be
something like you know i am fahad
that's a rational statement an
irrational statement is like
hey man i'm a married bachelor right so
if i come to you
imagine i come to you and i say i'm a
married bachelor i mean what are you
gonna say
i mean what like you try to convince me
towards sanity right like okay so
how right what would you say to me like
if i said i'm a married bachelor
what help me out here like i would just
be like okay that's nice
here's the number to the to the local
you know insane asylum
what are you gonna do right like what
how do you approach that
you just ask how that works yeah ask how
that works and you're like well it's
just it just works because i said it
works that's just how it is man
it doesn't make sense yeah what do you
mean doesn't it make what do you mean
doesn't make sense
i think it does those are two polar
opposites they can't
exist at the same time well you say they
can't exist at the same time i say they
can
what i'm getting at is that look in
order for this
particular idea to not make sense you we
understand that a bachelor is someone
who's not married
okay and someone's married is not a
bachelor so they're they're what they
call mutually exclusive
okay so that's a logical principle but
let's say i come now i say look i want
you to
prove the principle can you do it
i'm not saying prove it wrong i'm saying
prove the principle itself
you can't prove the principle so the
logic you have to have a starting point
that you cannot prove but you have to
accept
and in philosophy they call these first
principles or basic beliefs
you can't prove them but you can't move
forward unless unless you agree to them
right
and so in reality rationality has three
categories
you have that which is irrational that
which is rational and that which lies
outside of rationality
which you might call super irrational
from the islamic standpoint
that which is outside of rationality is
the fitra
right that original base state so part
of the fitra is things like logical
principles
you can't prove them but you have to
start with them right things that are
part of the fitra are
your um your aesthetic
sense right like if you go and you see a
sunset
and you look at your your friend or your
spouse or whatever you say man that's
beautiful
and the guy says dude that is the
ugliest thing i've ever seen
prove to me rationally that's a
beautiful sunset right can you do it
no right because that is a point that
you can't it's just it is what it is
right there's no sort of rational proof
and
you know and other things like your
sense of smell
like you walk in the room and something
smells terrible and some guy walks in
he's like
take it in bro it's amazing you're like
what are you like what are you talking
about right
like no prove to me rationally that that
you know it's it stinks in here
it's so these concepts we say that
they're outside of rationality
now the issue that arises is that if
someone says no
i say you can prove everything
right i say you can have you can have a
rational proof for everything
there's a certain problem with that
because when you're demanding a rational
proof for something
you're asking the question why you have
a doubt
right i'm not going to believe it until
you prove it so you doubt you ask why
you cannot ask why infinitely
you cannot just say there's no theorem
that is infinitely defendable
you can't say why why because because
this because it to infinity
there has to be a stopping point it's
like i tell people like my son he walks
in the kitchen
and he takes out the knife from whatever
the the place
and i say abraham put that back he's
like why i'm like well because it's
sharp you know
it'll cut you he's like why well because
it's sharp he's like well why
i'm like well because they manufactured
it like that he's like why i'm like well
because knives are used for cutting
things he's like why
i'm like well because you can cut fruit
he's like well why i'm like fruit
is better when it's cut he's like why at
a certain point it's like because i said
so i'm your dad man
right there's no like you can't ask why
infinitely there has to be a stopping
point because what you're saying is
i doubt what you're saying and you
cannot doubt things infinitely
because here's the other thing if you
say i
doubt everything then you have to doubt
your doubt
and that leaves you intellectually
paralyzed around people and so
you know there are certain names of
allah al-wahid
right the one and the one who is the
compeller you're compelled into a
position
of having an absolute that you whether
you accept it or not you have to believe
in an absolute
and from our perspective allah allah is
the absolute
right so rationality is an amazing tool
but it needs something external to it
right so it's like someone who comes and
says
i have the perfect solvent it can it can
dissolve
anything you just pour it it'll dissolve
through right
but you want to ask that person what
bottle are you going to keep it in
you might have the perfect solvent you
still need a bottle right it is not
absolute the term absolute
comes from that which is soluble right
absolute is not soluble
not solvable you cannot prove everything
to
you know wits end you have to have a
starting point
now when you come to the quran what's
interesting is that like i said
does allah not know what he created he
knows that he created this human being
on the state of fitra and so when when
you go to the quran you'll notice
there are not like discursive arguments
that are presented in the quran like
you know like you know how we reason we
say premise a premise b
therefore c right you're not going to
find that in the quran rather what you
find
is an attract or there is there are ayat
the concept of an ayah is very different
than a pure rational argument that
doesn't mean that
there's no rational arguments in the
quran but what an ayah does
is that it now targets not like if you
think about the three levels of
rationality
you've got your super rational rational
irrational right your fitrah your
and whatever is right you've got so
those three categories
the quran in fact is targeting these top
two
the fitrah plus rationality not just
rationality but both of them
and the ayah is in fact more powerful
than just a pure rational argument right
because what's an ayah
so an ayah um like sometimes you say
it's a sign
right and then this whole study called
semiotics which is very interesting when
you talk about the study of signs
and a sign if you think about it um like
the term ayah it comes from the
trilateral root alif yeah yeah
and so if you're going to distinguish
something from something else you're
going to say
hey you right which of these actions are
the best
so you've got a whole bunch of items you
want to pick one out
so what an ayah does in fact it has two
kind of primary characteristics
number one it's not time bound it's
immediate
right number two there's no information
transfer meaning you don't have to
go to university to figure out here's an
ayah so just to give an example so i
mentioned i
i graduated from michigan state right
so imagine now that i um it's 10 20
years later
i'm unpacking my stuff and i find my
my cap and my gown right that i wore to
to my graduation ceremony
now as soon as i pull it out immediately
i'm taken back
to the day i graduated right like the
look on my parents face
you know the fact that my last name
starts with a t and i had to wait for
200 people before i was able to go on
stage
that annoyance immediately comes back
did i learn new information
no but that became an ayah quote
a sign for something that was just
already deep inside of myself
so what an ayah does it takes that
reality within yourself
and brings it to the surface right and
that can happen in different ways but
the quran uses that as a tool
and why because the human construct
cannot
survive you cannot have an argument
without the fitra
you cannot have a a a first principle
less argument right it's like me just
saying
okay i'm a bachelor prove the principle
you can't
you have to assume it right that's why
the target is the first principle
subhan allah that's amazing so what do
you say
this might sound basic right we believe
the quran is 100 true
yes what do you say to an extent
most or a lot of what's in the quran is
just a series of first principles
and then we can come to rationally
understand it
no i wouldn't say that the majority of
the quran's first principles right i'm
saying that ayat
are those things that are are going to
basically be
something that the fitrah and the
recognized the fitra and
the rationality recognize i'm not saying
it's going to be fitra only although it
could be
yeah but it's not devoid of rationality
either because then that's the other
thing to say like it's only the fitrah
it's only your
that that that that state you were
created upon right but that's not true
either because allah subhanahu wa
tells us that we you know do we do they
not use their intellect
yeah but the idea is that it's not an
intellect in a vacuum
it's an intellect with the fitra right
so you wouldn't say that um
that the whole thing is just first
principles because in essence even
logically that would be problematic
i don't want to get into how but it just
it would break down right because you
need to have first principles and build
your arguments from there
right yeah yeah subhanallah yeah the
reason i mention that is because a lot
of the time you'll have a very
specific ayah in the quran that we build
full deductive arguments from yeah right
like imam khazali taking um
where they created from nothing and so
on and so forth i think coming to the um
cosmological argument yep yep you know
i'll be honest
uh i probably shouldn't say this but i'm
gonna go ahead and say it so a lot of
those arguments
like a lot of times i'm not i'm not sure
how effective they are
like in a just a conversation with
someone you know sometimes those
arguments i mean
yeah they're very powerful and for some
people it may be a means by which their
their fitra would be unclouded like
they'd be able to see
kind of like okay the the base is behind
it but sometimes man i mean especially
when it comes to
to the existence of allah i really feel
it's it's usually something else
it's either like a traumatic experience
the person had like they may have lost a
loved one to cancer or something right
and they're just dealing with that
they've kind of just rejected that or
it's the environment that they're in
and a lot of times we we take this
almost overly sophisticated you know
academic approach
when that's not the medicine that's
required right they need something else
they need
you know kind of a a spiritual you know
like
you know something that'll kick their
spiritual endorphins in in into action
right and which doesn't have to do with
here's the kalam cosmological argument
with all deference to that i mean i'm
not saying don't use them
i'm saying like we have to understand
the human being at the end of the day
i just had a quick question so did you
uh yourself make episode three or four
of the no doubt
series i think i did four and
five okay yeah i had a feeling i knew
i knew where i got that from ah okay
okay
yeah so
yeah so that's um that's generally the
approach that i have when it comes to
dawah and understanding the human being
um and then that gives us a
a nice way to um
move forward both from our both from
ourselves when we understand
what is the reality of ourself versus
just the um just this like
you know robotic reality this material
reality right
and the material world man it's gonna
it's gonna distract you right your
animal self is gonna be constantly
calling out and saying man just
just eat now sleep now you know do this
now
and um and we you know it it
it becomes important for us to kind of
reconnect with allah and kind of come
back
you know and a lot of times you know
when we're making dawah to people what
we're in essence trying to do is to get
them
to understand who they are like what is
the
the ontological reality of this person
you know
like you know you spent your whole life
and and maybe
like core existential questions are just
they've never been answered
you know i mean one of the things that i
tell when i speak to muslims
specifically
i say you know when you think about
existential questions
questions about your existence how did
you get here where you know what's your
purpose and what happens when you die
you know maybe growing up those
questions were answered
and so there's this this existential
comfort that you have right like those
questions are answered so i don't have
to worry about what's the purpose of
life
right i'm not worried about like what
happens after i die like i already know
that
and now i can work in that world view
and that paradigm
but for someone that doesn't know about
islam
um those are open questions and those
are
things that can deeply affect someone to
the point where if you don't know the
answer those questions
it can drive you mad like you guys have
heard um hamza's like airplane example
right have you guys heard that example i
believe so i believe so all right so
maybe romney's heard i don't know
i'll i'll i'll go through it again it's
a really good example
where i mean it's basically like a
thought experiment and and um
you know he you know the example is just
this that like as you're listening to me
talk
right now imagine you black out and then
you wake up and you're on a plane
all right and you're in first class and
the seats are really comfortable
and uh you know you look outside and and
and the
view is gorgeous it's like that orange
hue you know like right before sunset
so it's very pleasing to the eyes you
know uh and the temperature is perfect
you know one of the issues we have here
in houston is everyone's always fighting
or the air conditioning
right so the temperature in the plane is
just how you want it it's
perfect and after a few minutes you know
they come with the food
so you know you get haleem whatever your
favorite food is
and you put this food in your mouth
steak haleem burgers whatever you know
whatever it is and it just mel it's like
the best you've ever had
yeah so you're you were here listening
to me talk
you blacked out now you're on a plane
first class seats are comfortable
would you be happy now you might say
yeah
i'd be i'd be thinking like this man
drugged me
you no but your question would be how
did i get here
yeah right like that that's why you're
asking how does this person drug me
like how did i get here you know and
then and then and then
what am i doing here and i usually say
my question would be like
where is the damn plane going man like
where is this plane going right
like okay i'm here but from us from a
certain sense
your life you come into a state of
consciousness like that like at a
certain point
you're on this metaphoric plane and
if those questions aren't answered it's
like you're on that plane and you have
this discomfort
where is this plane going why am i on
this plane
you know and where did i come from and
where's where what happens you know
and just like so human beings if you
don't have those questions answered
because
you know you're like islam hasn't been
what you were brought up in or you've
never been exposed to islam these are
deep
questions and a lot of times when people
are coming to argue with you and
they want to debate with you those core
questions are still kind of lingering
and if you miss those questions you've
missed the vote in a sense
right you can get into these nuanced
areas of like the existence of god and
you know the kalam cosmological argument
and madrid whatever right so you can get
in those things and that's fine and
maybe that's what the person needs but
maybe the person is really just on this
journey and they have no idea of
where they're supposed to be going and
you just presenting to them islam
say look man you know this journey this
metaphoric journey that you're on
it's just about you you came from uh the
creator of the heavens and the earth
you know this being that is the most
merciful the one that you're going to
return back to
you know your purpose in life is to
worship praise
and submit to allah right that's why you
were created
i did not create the human beings and
the jinn except for worship
and what happens when you die when you
die you're going to be judged for your
actions
right and so that is the entire
construct
entire world view that so many people
have no idea about
because they're just lost in the
stratosphere of islam is evil and y'all
were just a bunch of terrorists
and also so they're they're missing the
boat but from another perspective
we're not presenting like hey this is
islam right this is
the existential comfort that comes with
someone who is
on a journey towards the hereafter and
on a journey towards spiritually
connecting with allah
you know so i think that you know i just
so with all deference to the arguments
like i actually teach the arguments we
do a class called
the divine reality based on hamza's book
so it's like a you know we're going to
like 13 weeks or whatever
and i've gone through them like from
objective morality you know and and
first principles and all these different
arguments that
that he writes and they're really good
arguments don't get me wrong but even in
the introduction to the book he mentions
that he says
you know this is just a stepping stool
right this is a this is a tool
and you really have to be like a doctor
right to understand
what is the medicine this person needs
right it can be rational arguments
but it might just be you know answering
existential questions
it might be experiences man like a lot
of times we
we downplay experiences you know um
and i always think i said you know if
you think about someone's experience
that is more powerful than just trying
to rationally convince yourself of
something
you know like okay so there's an
interesting thought experiment
um back in i think it's 1985
conducted by frank jackson it's called
mary's room
have you heard about it no so it's
really interesting he he does he he
presented his thought experiment
talking about is experience real or is
it his experience
knowledge right and so he says that
imagine that there's a woman named mary
and she is an expert in color theory
like she knows
and she she has a phd in color theory
and she has a phd in neuroscience
so she understands the neurological
functioning of the brain
like better than anyone and she
understands the concept of color
like the the spectrum and all these
things however
mary has been in a black and white room
her entire life and everything around
her is black and white
the the computer she's working on the
chalkboard the books
but she knows color theory she's a phd
in both of these color theory and uh
neurology or you know and so she
understands all these things
and so and but her whole life is just
around black and white
now at one point her computer her laptop
malfunctions
and a red apple shows up
has she gained some sort of knowledge
that's the question
right like you understand it's all but
so now she already know she's got the
expertise
in terms of in terms of knowledge but
does that experience of red has that
added something
to her knowledge or is that just
something else you know what i'm saying
it would be cementing yeah and a lot and
the and
from the islamic con construct
experience actually has a
a pretty high level so um within the
islamic construct you find for instance
the idea of certainty and within islam
certainty has
three levels right so in the quran as
you as you
go through it you find there's something
called um you know
certainty is called japin so you have
like not like knowledge that you're
certain about
right then you have like knowledge that
you've seen like you know something by
way of visualization
and then you have hakko yakin something
that you experience and you've
experienced and because you experienced
it you know it's a reality
right so you know i think ibn al-qaeda
mentioned the example of someone
presenting to you honey
right so someone tells you that there's
this really good honey it has
it's um it tastes amazing and you trust
this person
so you have a level of certainty because
of your trust of the person so that's
like
like you're you've kind of viewed it
maybe not directly but indirectly
because you're hearing it from this
person but
at a certain point what happens is is
that you have so you have this knowledge
then you see the honey and you smell the
honey right so someone told you about it
you have a knowledge of it
now you see it you smell it it smells
good so that's another
another level of certainty but then when
you taste the honey
now your level of certainty has gone
through the roof right now you're
absolutely certain because you've tasted
it yourself
right so you've got three levels and in
fact um
scholars mentioned that this is really
important when it comes to the concept
of how
you know how you die basically right
like every
human knows they're gonna die like like
they have the knowledge
they're certain about right very few
people say like yeah i'm not gonna die
right i mean if someone says that you
might tell them like look man you know
like
you're trying to tell me like you know
you go to one of these highways out in
l.a and your head doesn't come off like
come on dude like you're not gonna die
but most people
know that for a fact like we all know
we're gonna die it's
it's a knowledge that's there okay and
then
from like when you go through the quran
you see that
when you're about to die when you're at
the last throws of your death
you see the angel of death coming so
your level of certainty
upon seeing the angel of death is much
higher now
right and then when your soul is being
taken out of your body
you're experiencing death and so now
your level of certainty is even higher
so you move from you know
the knowledge site
right that that uh ocular site that you
have
to hakalia like experiential knowledge
because you now ex
i mean it's too late now but you get
what i mean right
so certainty has levels as well and so
sometimes my point what i was trying to
say is sometimes
an experience for someone can be more
powerful in the rational arguments you
present to them
you could take someone to like you know
let's see it goes you know
because we're talking about you know
canada and the us here you could take
someone to the niagara falls
the canada side right okay obviously and
so because if you've been there you know
the
american side is not as uh not as nice
as the canadian side anyway
so you take in niagara falls sometimes
just that
that state of awe that a person enters
into
because aw is a reality you experience
all when you go to a
you know like a like a mountainous area
just the grand
the grandeur of the mountain makes you
feel really small and you have this
feeling that
how do you describe it you know you
can't
and yet that experience could be the
means for you to say look man
think about the one who created all of
that think about the reason
you know like think about if if you feel
like that
in the state from a mountain or from a
waterfall that's just
grandiose think about the one who
created the mount the waterfall or the
one who created the mountain
how what sort of state of all will you
be in as you're facing that being
you know so sometimes it's not just
rational arguments it's not just
existential questions sometimes it's
experience man
you know i mean uh hamza always says
that you know if
if someone comes and says hey man can i
pray with you he'll be like yeah let's
pray
because you don't know if that salah
that prayer will actually be the
experience
that brings them into islam right so
as a person who's calling people to
islam we understand that we have a lot
of different tools within our toolbox
and we have to act like merciful doctors
or teachers
as we're bringing people in right we
don't only have rationality we've got a
whole toolbox
because the human being is complex right
it's not a simple
logical robot so
anyway so far have you been to
niagara falls i'm assuming you are right
yeah i've been to magic falls yeah
yeah i know have you man
do you remember those those grand
canyons
it's kind of it's kind of over here you
haven't been the greatest
is it really overrated though really you
remember you remember the waterfalls
we've been to in iceland
yeah those nice ones that like parking
was free there were like three four
people there
that's the equivalent of niagara falls
except niagara falls you got
thousands of people going daily parking
20 30 40 bucks
it's crowded you can't even get anything
but then when we were in iceland we saw
things like that every day
no parking no admission fee just
everywhere just
you know creations of allah and we were
just in our so
trust me trust me when i tell you bro
niagara falls is overrated
this is this is all time with what fahad
is saying
mm-hmm yes where it's like oh i'm a
merry bachelor
the self-created perceived value of
niagara falls
it's just it's it's annoying man like
every time we have a relative from
you know because i'm from bangladesh we
have people from back home
we got people that don't know what it is
or what to do we got to be like all
right yo
get in the camry let's let's pack your
bags let's let's go to
go to niagara falls for the day yeah man
you already know man
and it's like they see it and they're
like yo i'm like
i waited my whole life for this moment
just to like see the falls and i'm like
man this is the 115th time this year man
i'm here like
you know i'll tell you another like
another one that really gets me
which i think is really odd is haven't
have any of you guys been to
to mecca and seen the kaaba no yeah
oh yeah okay so may allah make it easy
for you guys and allow you to
to go for hajj ramadan
if you if you ask someone that sees the
kaaba for the first time
like they will never be able to explain
it to you
because you're just in a state of awe
and it's just you can't explain it like
the
i remember when when when the first time
that i went uh
for umrah with my wife and we had gotten
there
right like just before sunrise
and you know we got there and we walked
in
and we saw the gaba and it was it's you
can't describe it
and i looked over my wife and she had
tears coming down her eyes
and it's just you're in this state of
awe you know and
and inshallah when you guys you will see
that for yourself man it's just
how do you explain that because it's not
necessarily the thing that you're
looking at
because in essence what are you really
looking at you're looking at a cube
right i mean just
why would that why would that have any
sort of impact on you you know
but it does and it's just you can't
describe it
and and you can't imagine someone saying
like well rationally prove to me that
that you know that state of all is
justified
it's not a question of rationality it's
your experience
you know um yeah so
yeah so you none of you guys have been
to the grand canyon
i have no no so i'll tell you uh yeah
you have okay that's something really
funny so talking about hype
it's a lot of people like grand canyon
you got to see this and that and so my
wife and i went
and she looked down and she's like oh
man it reminds me of johanna it reminds
me of the hellfire
what does she mean reminds her that's
just like what is this right
so she wasn't a state of awe that's for
sure she just you know like yo this
is ridiculous anyways sorry you had a
question man go for it sorry
yeah so okay now that you've mentioned
[Music]
the soul and you've mentioned all these
things which by the way it's all
enlightening
it's amazing and as you can tell we're
all very quiet we're just listening
because it's
this these are gym man these are they're
asleep
these are gems these are all gems that
you're dropping so
now something that i want to bring to
the table and you and i kind of briefly
spoke about this
on call a few days ago
but if you if you have a person who is
talking about
consciousness and they're talking about
guy consciousness
and you know i would i would like you to
go in depth in terms of like what
consciousness is
from my islamic perspective what the god
consciousness
is as well and then explain the
differences and how like
even if you attain god consciousness
that doesn't mean that you yourself are
god
right yeah of course all right so
and it's interesting that someone like
you mentioned would
might might kind of conflate the two
right to say like god consciousness is
just like conscious itself so
consciousness like we mentioned
this is like um an internal reality that
everyone experiences
right we talk about experiential
experiential knowledge so that's your
consciousness that's that's your
your your your your crux your reality
that's why
you can see things you can hear things
not the physical aspect of that but what
is the thing that actually
hears and sees right from an islamic
standpoint that's
part of yahuwah that's part of your soul
and your soul
is created right and so
um when you talk about god consciousness
a lot of times that the word that's
translated as god consciousness is a
word called taqwa
right and uh maybe it's a decent
translation
but the word taqwa actually doesn't mean
that you become one with god or anything
like that right
it means that you are constantly
in the state of um constantly in the
state of of of
being careful when it comes to yourself
so you're conscious
of your every action and so when you're
saying you're conscious that god is
watching you
if you want to look at it from that
perspective so from an islamic
standpoint
when we say god consciousness we're not
talking about like this merger of god
and my consciousness or anything like
that
we're talking about a person who's god
conscious in the sense that
their conscience of god is watching me
and i need to be on my best behavior
right so like a simplified example might
be
like when you're gunning it down a road
and then you know you see a cop and you
slam the brakes right you just became
you know cop consciousness or whatever
right
that's your state so a person who's god
conscious
who's constantly in the state they're
always going to
let's say treat their parents well
because they understand that
you know if god is watching i need to i
need to be on my best behavior
you know they're going to be people who
are charitable because they understand
that the reality is that god is always
watching
and that i should be conscious of that
so that's a spiritual state that a
person enters into
between the relationship of a human
being being
limited and god who is unlimited
right so any sort of concept of
consciousness kind of just being
one with god this becomes problematic
because
a it doesn't it's not something that you
can um
let's say intellectually prove right
and so this is where in the beginning if
you remember i said we understand fitra
and then we understand rationality we're
not saying you throw away rationality
but what we're saying is understand that
it has a basis so here you may want to
consider
a rational argument to say look man if
we're talking about consciousness
were you always conscious right that
because and you would experience that
and the reality is no
you you weren't conscious when you were
born you didn't see yourself coming out
right or anything like that so clearly
there's a limitation
and when we think about the creation of
the heavens and the earth
you think about that that comes from a
source that is infinite that it's it's
it's
it's it's not limited so you're limited
and you have that which is unlimited you
have a creator
and then you are the being that's
created
and so therefore you are by necessity
not gonna have a some sort of a direct
like you know you'd not be at one
with god in some sort of you know
pantheistic way
if that makes sense
it's really is related so wasn't there a
hadith where um
was like describing taqwa with like the
thorns and the
yeah it's like it's like basically when
you're when you're going through a
thorny patch
and you raise your you raise your lower
garment your
and you try to make sure you're not
stepping on the thorns right that's the
example that was given you know
um that's what you're being conscious to
just make sure you're not
you're being thorn conscious i guess
right
so it's similar right it's uh uh you
just
and and there's other dimensions to it
as well so you can have like tako of
allah
and in the quran it's mentioned having
taqwa of the hellfire right
right you can you know be conscious of
the fire because you don't want to enter
it
right so you know you'll be conscious of
god because you don't want to anger god
right sometimes they talk about having
taqwa of your spouse
because you don't want to anger your
spouse so you have this
spouse or you know you know spouse
consciousness
um because you want to be careful and so
you understand that when a person sins
that could be you know that could be the
means that could be a reason
um for allah's anger right so you want
to be careful with that so the
concept of consciousness against you
know god consciousness unfortunately
you know translations sometimes do that
where you know they take a certain
concept and the concept itself is not
like it is in the arabic language you
know um so sometimes they translate as
god you know fearing of god but then
that that has another connotation
are we saying that god is just some sort
of wrathful vengeful god that you should
fear him
well no it's not that either right it's
kind of like it's this
state of like awe right like when you're
in a state of awe you are in a state of
fear
but not in a fear where like oh my gosh
it's like freddy krueger showed up
you're not in that service or like jason
or whatever that's not not that kind of
fear but just the overwhelming
you know mountain or whatever it is you
still have a concept of fear but it's
it's one of awe which is different
right yeah i want to tie in a personal
example now sure
the entire i don't know if these two can
relate but me personally
i'm going to put myself out there now i
was in a state of all this entire
conversation
and i was scared i was going to say
something dumb or interrupt you or or
kinda you know
like mess up the mess up the flow so i'm
like a fearful in that sense but i don't
fear you or anybody here but i'm still
in awe
so i feel like me myself i had to talk
with this this entire call
male accepted man i mean
all right what are you gonna say but um
okay if i had so
with everything you've said uh with what
you said about the
roof what you said about the uh
the god consciousness how do you how do
you say the uh the arabic word
all right so with everything you said
about that
we can pretty much deduce from it that
if
one person is fully present
meaning that they're not thinking about
anything they're not thinking about the
future they're not thinking about the
past
they're not repeating something in their
head if they're fully present
yeah just here like let's say they go
outside and they see birds flying
they are fully experiencing that that
right there
would just be how do i refer to this as
it would be you the rope
actually experiencing the dunya or
having this
experience and what it is like being in
that plane
and then you realizing oh i'm on this
plane yeah
yeah you know like and you're just
experiencing everything firsthand
but that doesn't mean that that's it
that that's the end right
correct of course yeah no absolutely
yeah and that's that's the thing man
like some people
get that twisted where they think that
okay reaching
that presence reaching that ability to
be a hundred percent present
and having that uh level of
consciousness is
the cream of the crop is enlightenment
it is what everyone should attain and
like there's nothing else past that
yeah i mean so the problem with
something like that is that it becomes
difficult to
uh substantiate that right so like for
instance
a lot of times i'll have conversations
with christians and um
you know let's say you know i believe in
god because of my my experience
you know and that's fine like i i don't
have a problem with experience i think
experience is is a valid form of getting
to the truth
but i don't think it's the only form of
getting the truth because you do
at the end it's not like you just turn
off your rationale and say like well i
experienced it and so therefore that's
that's it
right you still have a mind to think
with right
so if the two are not in step um
you've got a problem right even though
you may be quote-unquote experiencing
something
but how do you know that experience is
valid when you have a tool and that tool
is your mind
you know so it's not one without the
other let's put it that way
so if you're if you're saying that con
that's the that's the final level i'm
gonna reach a state of consciousness and
that's it i've basically maxed out
okay but how do you know that how do you
get to the place where like yes i know
that
how do you know that is it by way of
that experience because if it's by way
of that experience and that's only
limited to you
and only you can know that you can't
really convince anyone else of that
that's number one
number two how do you convince yourself
of that
right if it's not by way of rationality
yeah
man like everything that you're saying
and and these points that i'm bringing
up is because i had a conversation
yeah you mentioned a very close brother
yeah and it actually got even
deeper than the little tiny bit that i
mentioned over the call with you
right but um he just he just kept going
on about like
consciousness and this whole aspect as
like uh
there's no god and that it's it's all
consciousness i'm like that
doesn't make sense right you can't have
it and then
and then i told him kind of like what
you said where it's like all right if
you
if you see this waterfall and it blows
your mind it leaves you in awe imagine
you seeing the creator experiencing the
creator yeah imagine what that would
leave you in and we leave you in
submission we'll leave you in
prostration it will leave you just
out of this world like something
different we can't even explain what it
would leave you in
man and i told him the same thing man
and right
yeah no i mean look it it's it leads to
a whole bunch of problems too by the way
like think about morality like how how
do you how do you define morals then
if you and the creator are one then you
just do what you want you define
morality
right and it's like if that's the case
then you can never make a moral claim
that something is
objectively moral now what i mean by
that
uh is that you know if you ask someone
is
is is rape wrong and they said well yeah
of course it's wrong
it's okay imagine the whole world came
together and said that rape is okay
would it be okay and the person says no
be like okay so you say that rape is
objectively immoral it doesn't matter
it's not it's not subject to a human
being's limited mind and emotion
even if the whole world came together
and said it was wrong right
or said it was okay you would still
believe it's wrong if the person says
yes be like okay
why if that only comes from you it's
still subjective
you have to have an external source
right by which you can have a moral
anchor
to attach that to so if you're going to
say that consciousness and that's it and
there's all there is
what's your moral anchor if it's just
you then it's still subjective
and it's just you your opinion versus my
opinion you can never say something is
morally correct or morally incorrect sex
i was i was telling him like you can't
have consciousness without the creator
yeah exactly like where did you start
and like you
the creator said like okay now you'll be
and
he you put the roof and i don't really
know how to say
yeah perfectly so forgive me if i am no
it's all good butchering it
but um he put that in us and he's giving
us the
ability to be conscious yeah it's like
you you can't have one without the other
so it's like when he when this guy
brought up
uh both of them and he was just missing
one and saying well it's only this
right i'm like well okay now you're just
you're kind of
stuck in between like an atheistic point
and then like uh
this new age point where like if you
look at the new age people they really
only believe in like
consciousness spirituality right and um
i don't know let me let me stop right
there you understand i like the whole
point i like
just mentioned about you can't have one
without the other because without
god without allah you don't have
consciousness but without consciousness
you can't fully connect and understand
allah
that's true exactly yeah i feel like the
issue is a lot of the time
one like one extreme the birth of one
extreme birth to other extreme right
so if you have people who are only like
rational logical deduction that's it
then you're gonna have people that are
like okay but what about the spiritual
slide and then they turn only
spiritually and they don't even want to
deal
with the logical part and then you have
the other side people like even muslims
who grow up
they're told to you know have taqwa of
allah and all that they're taught with
just this
um the spiritual side they're never
really taught the why they're never
really taught
um this is why you need to connect to
allah this is the logical side this is
how it's even provable and to a certain
extent
so then they jump to atheism there's
atheism they're like oh this is logical
i don't want any of that stuff anymore
right right no i mean it's dude it's
it's it's been a um
what do you want to call it it's a uh
it's a perennial disease
in the sense that it's not like it's
just our generation
right i mean this is from the very
get-go what was the problem with
uh bani israel right the the jews from
before
their issue was that they were very
stringent upon
the letter of the law like that you know
the specific
legal aspect and they've completely
forgotten the spirit of the law
right so if something was haram it was
haram no matter what
right even whether it's smaller there's
no sort of wisdom behind it
right and so then you have a reaction to
that which is christianity
and christianity said you know forget
the law
everything is just it's all good right
like jesus died for my sins so i can
just do what i want
so now you've got these extremes and
islam has always been
in the middle it's the book
the law and the wisdom behind it and so
you take these in tandem
so even when you know and and this is
true for even the muslim community
you have some people that are that are
really overly strict when it comes to
uh you know the right to the point where
it's like
the smallest minutiae of something like
man your beard you know it's not long
enough you're an inch short whatever and
you know this is just
and at the same time this person is uh
you know i don't know maybe he's like
you know he's he's surfing porn sites
you know just
just as an example so you've got this
major issue that's gonna
you know be detrimental spiritually but
you're so focused on the minutia
and you've lost the entire idea right so
you've got
even the muslim community got that
extreme as well then you have the other
extreme in the muslim community as well
all right well look it's just all about
spirituality and as long as i'm a good
person
and everything's good well then i'm good
right i don't need to worry about rules
and regulations and all that stuff
and it's always about the middle because
they have a connection with each other
right you you know your your
spirituality is enhanced by
following the law and and by following
the law your spirituality is enhanced
and it's actually
one works on the other that's why when
the sahaba were described
abdullah masood describes the sahaba the
companions he said they had knowledge
upon action and action upon knowledge
piety upon
uh piety upon knowledge and piety upon
and knowledge upon piety
it was circular the more they would
learn the more they would get closer to
god
and the more they get closer to god the
more that would allow them to learn
and so it was a balanced approach and
islam
we have made you as a balanced middle
nation right so when you're looking at
and
and you know uh you know like if you're
if you're here in the states you're
looking at
kind of the the political area right
like in terms of like you have like this
extreme liberalism
and you have extreme conservativism
right you've got like your republicans
that are going nuts and you have your
democrats that are going nuts
right and islam is always in the middle
right it's like you've gone
like you know some of the stuff that
conservatives say in general
in the political sphere is so crazy that
it's like that's
insane but at the same time you have
people on the left side
that are saying things that are crazy as
well right
because people you know they go to
extremes and it's not a new issue
it's it's perennial it's like it happens
from the beginning and the way to combat
that
is to have a connection with allah and a
connection with the quran
and constantly working on yourself and
your relationship with allah
you know
man that's powerful i think connecting
to allah disconnects you from all these
differences and limitations you you can
like connect with all the other people
around you
we think we're so different and we think
you know this person's that or that
person that but it really doesn't matter
and the perfect example from people that
i know that went to omran hajj
is when they go there you got people
that are black
white latino american you got you got
asian people and it doesn't matter at
the end of the day where you came from
what you do for a living where you were
born where you were raised what language
you speak you're all here for one cause
yeah man i mean your rule doesn't have a
color
at least one you can't perceive it's
only your
your your material existence man and
you're gonna make a judgment based on
that thing which isn't really you anyway
right
your reality is something that's not
really you know based on
on something as superficial as color or
looks or
skin tone or whatever it might be you
know and that's what's you know that
that's what's beautiful about even like
when i went for hajj
you're right man i mean there's no
you're there in two sheets
you know and you know the thing is when
when
when we die uh the muslim is buried in
two sheets
so it actually brings your reality uh
closer in a sense because it's reminding
you of the inevitable end
you know and as as a spiritual tool
thinking about death is an excellent way
for you to kind of wake up if you're if
you've come into this state of
slumber with a relationship with allah
right in fact
the prophet muhammad saw sallam he even
said
[Music]
make much mention of the destroyer of
delights
death right and so if you if you think
about
death you know one of the things about
um american society is that
they hate talking about death in general
there's a really interesting book called
um
will my cat eat my eyes out uh by
catelyn dodie
and um and the book she's a mortician
and so she deals with dead bodies
basically so when you know when you when
when people die she's the one that
dresses them up puts on the wax whatever
it is
and sets it up for people to come and so
as a mortician
she said um that americans are the most
death illiterate people on the planet
right
like we don't we don't even wanna we we
have different words for it
oh they passed you know she passed away
uh they're in a better place like even
the word like
if you went to someone said yo he died
you know it's almost like
just the words themselves are they just
have a certain weight you're just like
whoa that
almost disrespecting the person you know
um
but the reality is what death does is
that it brings you to a certain reality
a certain state that you understand that
there are things that are more important
than just the
the the the ups and downs and the
vicissitudes of life
right that you're going to go back to
allah and that's inevitable
you know and that constant you know
reminder of death
helps you spiritually because then it's
not about what does this person
think about me how good do i look on
instagram none of that's gonna matter
right you don't take your toys with you
when you go right and you can have all
the toys you want
at the end the end is the end and so you
know
it's um it's one of those things man
it's just you know
thinking about death it's it's it's it's
very powerful
and unfortunate a lot of us don't really
utilize that it reminds me of that same
memento morty
what is that it basically means remember
your death
yeah yeah absolutely yeah and i've i've
been following that for like the past
five years
and people always say like oh well why
you
why do you think like that that's
depressing yeah
why would you do that i'm like are you
serious like
the fact that i remember my death allows
me to live
more because it's like if you think that
you're not gonna die if you don't
remember that you are going to pass or
not that you are going to die eventually
then you're not you're not going to take
advantage of
whatever it is that you have like the
time that you have here
whereas like yeah go ahead go ahead and
then the question of like purpose and
things like that then it doesn't matter
because you're just you know you're just
living in the present and that's it and
you could care less
and that becomes problematic because you
know in the end you're
you're the one that's going to lose out
you know
and that's uh that's that's sad from a
certain perspective
like then then why would you care about
purpose like your existence like those
existential questions
you know one of the best you know one of
the things that
that that modernity does or like the the
material modern world that we live in
is it's all about like forgetting that
you're gonna die
right i mean that's basically what it's
about because you're so busy
with all of you know whatever social
media movies netflix whatever it might
be
you're so busy with those things you're
living
somebody else's reality or not even not
even somebody else's reality but
just something that's not even real
you're in that world for so long that
you've forgotten that you actually exist
man and you have a you have a
you have a duty and you have a place
that you're going you're on that
metaphoric plane
you know but you're just enjoying the
stake or the haleem or whatever it is
and you care less about where the
plane's going
or why you're even there first um
my mom right my mom loves to watch
tv shows and all this stuff and
it's a distraction like you said it
distracts us from life
it puts us in another world in this fake
world
and then it's like eventually you have
to come back yeah
and like imagine if you're always
distracting yourself
and then when you have those moments
where you finally come back it's like
you realize
oh i'm actually doing nothing i'm doing
nothing in this life
and then it makes you so depressed that
you go and you distract yourself even
more
yeah it's like a vicious cycle you know
and it's uh yeah man i mean that's
that's the thing man life
is um you know i mean it's just
and a lot of times we distract ourselves
because we don't want to
we don't want to face like the the the
vicissitudes of life
like let's face man i mean life can be
challenging you know and
and each person is going to be tested
right that's part of the
part of our our belief as well is that
you know allah tests each person and
each person is going to have
a unique test where you know they're
going to be put to the test
right and um and sometimes that that's
hard to that's hard to cope with you
know so you just want to distract
yourself and not worry about
you know paying your bills or whatever
it might be right you know filling out
your insurance forms or
that stuff i mean that that's real
that's real life you know
and a way to distract yourself is just
well whatever get involved in
you know netflix whatever it is and that
that's that's the easy
the easy way out you know but uh but at
the end of the day it's not it's not
real
yeah all this is kind of summarized with
the verse in the quran where allah says
that basically this life is nothing but
delusion and enjoyment or delusionary
enjoyment
right like this life is nothing but a
xena it's like
you know like it's just like it's it's a
delusion right it's just not it's not
even real
in a certain sense right and it's just
mutual
uh you know competition and you know
boasting about the things that you have
you know and so that's really what it is
right you start collecting all these
toys and
why are you collecting them ah so i can
show my friend that i have you know the
latest whatever right like ps5 or
whatever it is that you
people collect right and so you know and
then you just get distracted by it and
that
that's and the return the return is to
allah at the end
yes
i couldn't help but think of the last
few verses of surah najam
yeah where allah allah basically like
this is a beautiful surah right and it
ends by saying
um
and then like this this messenger that
was sent to you
um the translation is slipping but
basically this is a warner this is a
messenger right something to warn you
and then as if it said like the the time
has come basically right that's it
time has come if a man had the hadith
do not reflect on this verb like are you
not you know in awe of this verse you
this does not make you think
allah is like um
we're like uh and and you're laughing
and you're not crying about these verses
these are something
that should emotionally move you yeah
right yeah
and then what we're doing prostrate to
your lord and worship him and like right
right yes yes it's it's very i mean
those those ayats from sudan they're
very powerful it reminds me
like uh like the prophet muhammad he
said if you knew what i knew
you would laugh little and cry much
right
because he knows that you know he he
knows he's a messenger of allah right so
he knows the reality of this world and
he knows the reality of
what happens on the day of judgment you
know and uh when we forget
those things just become you know they
kind of consume us you know we get lost
then we get worried
you know so there was a speaker who said
something really powerful
is that when you're lost in the
vicissitude the up
up and down the ups and downs of life
and you're just like oh my god like this
is just too much for me to handle
he goes you have in a sense forgotten
about who allah is right because
at the end of the day the one that
you're returning to
is the one that created you the one that
is
more merciful than your own mother right
the most merciful person in your life is
most likely your mother right the one
that
and allah is more merciful than that you
know and the one you're returning to
is the one who you know is is
the one who's good right is is the one
is
the one who is more loving than anyone
you know
right you know the one that's holy
and so that's the one you're so when
you're and and the speaker said that um
that it's like when you're you know in
life you sometimes get like flustered
he goes it's like if you have children
and you throw them in the air
i don't recommend you do this but anyway
so sometimes when a little kid you throw
them up right
and when they're on their way up they're
like scared
right they're like and then when they
come down you catch them and then
they're laughing
and like hey baba do it again and so he
said that you know when you're
up in the air like the child's up in the
air that's you in your life that's your
life basically like
everyone's like really worried and the
thing is the hands you're coming back to
are secure hands because they're the
hands of allah
you know and so it's like everyone just
needs to calm down and come back to
allah
and that's what it is at the end of the
day you know
so it's it's uh yeah man it's it's
that that's that's reality of the soul i
guess
thank you so much for this productive
talk um
well yeah before we i guess stop this
recording
and make an end to this podcast it's
just under two hours
what is your last final piece of advice
to anyone that is struggling with their
iman struggling with
connecting to allah coming back to that
state of like the natural way
and this could be for muslims it could
be for people that are non-muslims but
they're kind of interested in islam but
kind of not able to just connect to that
um so i mean just general advice and i
think we went through a few pieces
already
um but you know for for the muslims that
are out there
i think a lot of times uh we lack a
connection with the quran
which can be problematic right because
remember
we were talking about the the the
sustenance of the soul
and that comes from the quran and that's
you can never get tired of it right
so if you have let's say your limitation
is the arabic language for instance some
people say
well you know what i can't read the
quran because i don't know arabic you
know get a good translation
and just go through it man you know
it'll give you at least a sense of what
the quran says
right a translation i recommend is um
dr mustafa khattab's you know the clear
quran
it's a good translation you know the
other day i was going through it and i
was
very impressed because he he captured
some of those linguistic aspects that
like we spoke about and stuff like that
so it's a good translation you know
so connecting with the quran and then
the next level would be
engaging with the arabic language so you
can connect even deeper with the quran
you know i think one of the the
tragedies of the
of the modern age for the muslims is
that
you know the disconnect from the from
the book of allah right
because the people of the past like ibn
al-qayyim said you know one of the
spiritual diseases
to for you to reflect upon is um
how much of the quran how much of your
daily reading of the quran
did you limit and i started thinking
about that i'm like he's talking about
limiting like a daily recitation most
there's muslims who haven't recited the
quran they only do like ramadan ramadan
right forget daily recitation right
you're talking about like yearly
like okay i'll listen to the quran
ramadan and then next ramadan i'll come
and i'll listen to it again
i mean what do you expect you know so if
a person is
if you're muslim it's time to take a
journey to the quran
engage with it because this is kalam
allah this is the word of allah
and those are things that it'll elevate
your iman in ways that you cannot
you can't describe it you know and just
having that that
you know one of the other issues about
this day and age is people generally
just don't like to read
so that becomes a problem right because
people just want a quick tweet
or just want to see a video on it or
whatever it might be and you got to
fight that and actually read you know
and come back to the quran
so that's for i guess the muslims that
may be struggling with their iman that's
just one
kind of piece of advice and there's
other things we can get into but at
least as a starting point
and as for someone who's who's out there
who's just searching
i mean think about some of the stuff we
said in in the in the podcast today
right uh the idea is that there is an
objective reality
that is out there and that is that there
is
a law there's a creator and this creator
has assigned a purpose in life
right and you know it's not about you
know yourself and
you know what you believe to be true it
means you have to transcend your own ego
and that's really anytime you want to
learn anything
that's what you have to do because if
you have an ego it'll stop you from
learning and i'm not even talking about
islam
just anything like even within like if
if you
think you know right like you know
physics
you will never get to astrophysics
because
i already know i i'm i'm good but that
sense of knowing is going to stop you
because you you can't grow then right so
it's incumbent upon us to just have an
open mind and start to just explore
islam
you know kind of see what it's about go
to the quran you know
talk to you know people muslims whatever
it might be
and just start thinking about like those
existential questions we were talking
about
because that at the end at least one
thing that you
the viewer and other people can agree
upon no matter whether you're muslim or
non-muslim
you're going to die right and that's
basically something we can agree on
now the reality now the question is what
are you going to do about it
you know that would be my my final well
i'll tell you what i'm gonna do about it
i'm gonna drug myself so i end up on
that plane bro
the plane we don't know where it's going
um
for real alhamdulillah romney do you
want to close it off
yeah bless you this has
been an amazing amazing episode i was
trying to think like you
when you would say something like oh
that would be a good clip and i realized
this entire thing is just one giant
amazing clip
may allah bless you it means a lot thank
you for coming on
everybody watching comment down shaykh
is the og i don't know about all this if
you made it this far if you made it this
far
if you made it this far we're going to
have them back for a live stream
inshallah we have to inshallah one day
with that being said everybody
has
descriptions of how he looked he had an
aesthetic physique guys
most of our uncles and fathers and yeah
bro don't even get me started on that
most of
the people we got in our family or the
people we have like uncles and
grandfathers they we got in the dad bots
maybe they'd be getting these uh
unhealthy foods in
not drinking enough water not exercising
bro prophetic times
these were not weak people yeah mentally
or physically they looked
like doms and they were dumbs they
weren't out here just
kind of like you know soft and eating
and whatever and not really focusing on
the health the processor had an
aesthetic physique he had a good build
[Music]